attendez on se sent et brio et tu fais
même le titre c'est bien comme promo qui
trompe pas c'est original que tu es un
peu cul dans ce qu'il nomme et les
foules mais et les mecs vous êtes en
train de devenir si nos amis avec de
l'endroit on veut non mais pourquoi mais
je suis pas de cette conversation je
voulais que mal mais ça de moi alors on
attend un petit tour de top qui est
tellement proche de ses voisins qu'il
les entend même faire l'amour
ah oui mais chez moi c'est peut-être sur
course que j'ai vu sur un hôtel je sais
je suis déjà venu chez vous bon mais oui
je ne le réveille un jour à 4 heures du
matin il a jamais répondu l'élu peur
régis labeaume la bombe lacrymo derrière
vrai ou pas ouais c'est vrai ouais j'ai
même eu les montées par une échelle et
où il avait décidé à la fenêtre ouverte
ouais ouais il c'était la canicule
annoncée moi il ya un hôtel et donc je
vois des gens mais là on est en direct
[Applaudissements]
je la sentais à cette émission là à la
wiimote sans prendre garde
la tuerie et ils sont maintenant vous
dites le moi ce n'est parfois une crise
alors ça ça nous arrivera jamais quatre
jours ça va partir en cacahuète total
voulu alors louis xiv c'est moi j'ai un
hôtel et joie des gens parfois regarder
le replay tpm des c'est vrai ou parfois
faire pain ou des genres muel gigot mais
un gigot ou chatouiller le déni phare
[Musique]
c'est une autre époque faire des
galipettes au sénat ils vont vous à
chatouiller nos chances à tous les buts
du français à prendre jusqu alors pas
parlé de ça mais oui je voulais raconter
que moi j'avais entendu mes voisins mais
en fait je pensais qu'il se battait pas
ce que j'entendais des cris des morceaux
de bois j'entendais des frais c'est moi
ou vous habite à côté de la maison de
charles ingalls
j'aimerais bien on va confier entendu
des cris tellement fort que du coup j'ai
appelé la police
la police est intervenue et ma voisine
est arrivé les cheveux comme ça tout en
transpiration et elle m'a dit écoutez
moi si vous faites pas du bruit quand
vous faites l'amour c'est pas moi c'est
pas mon problème
moi en tout cas je m'éclate au pieu
alors amusez vous aussi alors oui elle
m'a dit moi je viens pas appelé la
police quand vous chantez au complet
[Rires]
il a tendu ses voix data stéphane
gavelle un truc toi que tes voisins tu
as déjà entendu tes voisins on mettait
fin à vendre à stéphane a vendu à 2 mais
apporte parce qu en fait j'étais au
premier et tous mes voisins metella
cendres de leur club sur google n'ont
pas fait tomber sur mes enfants je vais
me battre avec quelqu'un 28 ans
maintenant oui c'est pour ça et
maintenant j'ai un enfant qui joue du
piano juste à côté de ma chambre
ah ouais à 6h30 nom et ses parents je
renvoyais sérieusement je renvoyais la
plus belle lettre de gentilles et j'ai
envoyé mes dvd
enfin ils m'ont renvoyé mais pas
totalement neuf
non merci mais brin continue je sais
mais je comprends moi moi qui joue du
piano quand les gens se plaignent que je
joue mieux vaut ça ça m'énerve histoire
de jouets non mais je vous dis je fais
la 9e et là je la joue pendant des
heures il ya des gens qui se plaignent
samedi dans votre hôtel particulier on
ne vous entend ce 2-2 tard
alors que c'est là votre assurance
habite dans un immeuble ce qui s'est
passé le k bitton j'ai quelqu'un auger
quelqu'un en bas j'ai quelqu'un à côté
et les gens s'ils ne se plaignent pas à
son jardinier sa gouvernance
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
demandez c'est bien une francesca soirée
ça sent la fin de carrière vous avez
déjà entendu vos voisins à ma voisine
c'est ma mère alors alors et qui a déjà
était le voisin d'une star franchement
pour moi quand j'étais mannequin j'y
vais à new york dans la trump tower et
la tour de trump la prime tower
c'était comme s'il y avait ma chronique
hours of les gars et je viens dans un
petit appart qu'un copain l'avait prêté
ouais j'étais copine avec yvan cas qui
était mannequin aussi dans la même
agence de sarran il bancaire en hiver
votre iphone 4
en fait elle m'avait fait visiter son
appartement qui était un penthouse sur
deux étages en août d'être invité en
cause et j'avais croisé 2 voyons d'abord
vous avez parlé donald trump a qu'un
faux coup et c'est d'ailleurs pour
inscrire dans friends avait vu donald
kohn ouais et alors et à digoin me rien
en regard des intéressés parce que
j'étais un peu trop âgés ah ouais
j'avais 22 ans en fait
en fait je vous dirai pas si tu
démissionnes problème problème je l' ai
je le savais que le savait alors oui
avoue hec est là et il savait qu'il
était elle était voisine c'est la seule
clovis qu'en dix premiers dans mon
immeuble je sais pas si sa grande
voisine moyens je suis d'europe ça qu'on
prenne sa croix j'avais moi j'avais
habité moitié célarié et tonton david et
on adore j'avais michel sardou je me
rappelle toujours que c'est vrai et vous
l'attendiez chanter répétait tout ça
quoi parce que vous croyez vraiment
alors mais regardez-moi ces réponses
regardez c'est à dire qu'il croit que
des quand le mec il est chanteur ça lui
arrive en 3e michel roques et des
commerces bonjour michel ne m'a pas
déparé par une eva départ et c'est des
fous sinon vous non bah moi j'habitais à
côté d'un propre blog se fait pas
beaucoup de buts sont enchantés ni
appétit rends-toi vrai mais c'est bon
c'est l'habitat côtés de stars vous
n'ont jamais dit qu'ils avaient à del
vert était lui la star je te suis
obligea le plaza aujourd'hui oui
attention plaza de mayo qui a déjà eu
une aventure avec son voisin sa voisine
ou genre y avait un petit buy longtemps
on s'est vu par la fenêtre et à l'avant
centre dans le même cours de théâtre
sans se connaître et on se regarde on
n'y mettais ma voisine
non on a cru que c'était le destin qui
na waie réunis et on a un truc c'était
magique
non en fait c'était une histoire de
merde où il a quand même des choses à
vous dire moi quand j'étais dans le
massachusetts
alors oui détenus et mannequin j'ai vécu
on a tous été mal car nous fait mal car
on le dit pas mais bon le devoir d alain
petit j'avais un petit appartement à
noter son dos à tokyo où s'effectuait la
selle c'est un truc de fou quand même
une fin de carrière à ce que tentera
[Rires]
mais la main sans rigoler l'état new
york de deux minutes la halle à tokyo
dans cinq minutes elle va y trouver tout
cet automne j'ai fait comme un pays à
bas tous ont défilé comme ça sauf la
laponie j'y suis jamais allé à bâle et
on est allé on veut rêver
ouais il a une qui trouver l'amour là
bas haha ça fait rêver en tout cas bah
vous verriez vous allez voir le mec ça
fait vraiment aux néophytes appart à
tokyo moi et tout d'un coup je me
réveille en plein milieu de la nuit à 3
heures du matin je me sens pas bien je
tombe non oui des frères c'est un
tremblement y avait un tremblement terre
ce que là bas il ya toujours des
tremblements de terre en plané de la
nuit et de on se sent un peu et brieuc
et brio va bien voilà hébrides l'homme
du couple attendait on se sent et brio
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si je le savais je crois que ça voulait
dire que malpensa batum va tâcher de mal
comme ça cette démission et brio
mascella ah oui c'est ébriété mais
conduite ont conduit en état d'ivresse
alala ivresse les bouillons et brio pour
lire la naissance connaissez doigt la
messale connaissez brio toi sur trois
que ça promet
[Rires]